It's our netbooks, kids!
History teacher Luke Rosa wheels his cart filled with laptops into a classroom at Falls Church High School in Virginia.
I mean it's just like a regular textbook except it's got all online.
This school year, the Fairfax County Public School System...
...has shifted from hardcover to electronic textbooks...
...for social studies in its middle and high schools.
The system's assistant superintendent Peter Noonan...
... says the switch came after digital books were used in 15 schools last year.
Our students come to us technologically savvy and ready to utilize resources from a variety of different places.
Noonan points to the benefits of electronic textbooks such as the ability to update content.
The world is changing consistently and the online textbooks can change right along with the events that are happening.
And there's a significant financial benefit as well.
Usually it's in the neighborhood of between 50 and 70 dollars to buy a textbook for each student....
...which adds up to roughly eight million dollars for all of our students in Fairfax County.
We actually have purchased all the online textbooks for our students for just under six million dollars.
Students have mixed feelings about the switch, but most like it.
I don't have to carry a textbook around, so that's nice.
I don't like it because the Internet sometimes doesn't work.
You can highlight your work, you can leave notes on your work...
...and it will all be saved onto your account.
It's a lot better than a regular textbook.
How about gun control?
Social studies teacher Michael Bambara thinks so too.
Particularly this book that I use in government has differentiated reading levels,...
...so a person can individualize their learning and I can individualize their instruction.
However, making sure all students have online access outside school remains a challenge.
About ten percent of students in Fairfax County don't have a computer or online access at home.
Steven Castillo is one of them.
Pretty much go to a library, I guess, or go to a friend's house.
Besides the public library's free computer terminals,...
...students can also use the school's after-school computer lab...
...or go to one of the computer clubhouses supported by the county.
All of my family works on a computer.
My sister and me both do our homework on it.
So I come here to do my homework.
It's good.
Neighboring counties are also considering online textbooks.
Gladys Whitehead, Director of Curriculum of Prince George's County Public Schools,...
...says its survey shows 60 percent of students have computer access at home.
Next year, we'll just have a pilot with probably one classroom and one subject area,...
...so that we can see what issues will come up with complete online access.
I envision a future where my third grade son will likely not be carrying...
...five textbooks back and forth between high school and home when he gets there.
I think he'll be carrying either a tablet or some sort of device...
...that he will be able to access his information on.
And schools, says Peter Noonan, are taking the first steps in that direction now.
For producer June Soh, Amy Katz, VOA News.